[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think life would be like if
your neurons experience turnover just
like your skin cells that is if they
were born and died regularly like the
outer layer of your skin which has
turned over a thousand times during the
course of an average human lifespan we
don't feel a little bit like Clive
wearing the amnestic patient whose
Journal is just a series of sentences
like now I'm finally awake with each
previous one crossed out how would we
remember anything how would we learn
from our experiences would we be able to
build skills like language or driving or
playing the violin probably not and so
unlike most of the other cells in our
bodies our neurons stick around
most of them our partners for life
that's why neural development and
childhood is so critical if you don't
build those cells properly in the
beginning it's very hard to overcome the
disabilities that will resolve at the
other end of the lifespan these cells
are subject to some of the same effects
of aging that deteriorate other parts of
our bodies comparing performance by
people of different ages on many
cognitive tasks it's hard not to wonder
whether we reach our intellectual peak
in our 20s or 30s and then endure a long
slow inevitable decline and that's why
for decades after the first evidence
that demonstrated the birth of new brain
cells even in adults was published many
neuroscientists refused to shed the
dogma that once we reach adulthood we
only lose neurons we don't grow nuanced
it's not that our brains weren't thought
to change it was known that experience
shapes the very structure of our brain
cells that's one way in which learning
becomes embedded into our biology the
connections between neurons gets
strengthened ER we
and as memories are formed and forgotten
the amount of real estate that our
cortex assigns to different functions
changes depending on how we spend our
time and even the synchronisation of
millions of cells chanting together in a
chorus is malleable with experience we
call this malleability neuroplasticity
which refers to the long-lasting changes
that a brain can undergo throughout the
course of our lives
we use the term plastic because like
plastic the brain can be shaped into a
billion different forms giving each
person who ever lived a unique mind and
as we lay down these experiences we want
to hold on to them as long as possible
of course it's helpful to remember who
behave as a friend or a foe in the past
even if it's been years since your last
encounter these long-term memories are
part of the reason why neuroscientists
were so reluctant to accept the data
overturning the no new neurons dogma
throughout evolution our ancestors
brains changed dramatically over the
course of a few million years as they
began to use tools live in larger and
larger social groups cook food and so on
it made sense that the price that we pay
for remembering the past and learning
how to live together in relative harmony
ultimately building civilization was the
absence of neurogenesis the birth of new
neurons in adulthood as you can imagine
neuroplasticity an ever-changing brain
arguably captures our own experience of
our minds much more accurately than the
idea of a brain being a computer or
other machine whose parts don't change
thoughts come and go we learn and we
forget we improve and we regress but of
course there are some functions that
seem to be more amenable to change than
others it's easy to learn that someone
has changed her phone number because she
moved across the country it's hard to
remember what that new phone number is
when we've dialed the old one thousands
of times and as you're probably well
aware there are times in our lives when
our brains are more plastic than at
other times it's much easier to
in a new language if we've been exposed
to it before the age of five when our
brains are in what's called the critical
period for language acquisition but it's
not impossible to learn and even master
a language in adulthood it just requires
more effort and admittedly the process
by which a new language is acquired is a
bit different in adulthood compared with
how it works in childhood to understand
this difference and to begin to grasp
the nature of neuroplasticity
let's look at what's going on inside a
toddler's brain when I watch my toddler
jump from one activity than to the next
in mere minutes or when I try to keep
his attention on some tasks like
brushing his teeth or putting on pants I
sometimes get exasperated by his
inability to focus for any length of
time his attention span is so short but
actually a more accurate description
from his perspective is that his
intention is in fact almost infinite
he's paying attention to almost
everything which is why he gets
distracted so easily
his brain is awash with a protein called
brain derived neurotrophic factor or BD
and asked for short
BD NS plays an important role early in
our lives as it is encourages the growth
of new neurons and the formation of new
synapses so that cells can communicate
with each other it's prevalent during
critical periods in which neurons are
finding their places in the brain a time
of extensive neuroplasticity these
critical periods are why children who
are not exposed to certain types of
stimuli for example kids who are deaf or
visually impaired or aren't spoken to
must then endure a lifetime of
disability if a child doesn't get the
right type of stimulation his cells
won't organize themselves in such a way
that they can process that information
in the same way as in a healthy person
later in life but the work of BDNF isn't
finished once a child reaches adulthood
even in adulthood we now know that we do
grow new neurons and select parts of our
brain regions involved in long-term
memory so the idea that once you reach
your 20s
you're stuck with the brain cells that
you've got is a myth but note that
neurogenesis doesn't happen all over the
brain as we speculated at the top of the
lecture that would be a disaster instead
we have found adult neurogenesis in only
two parts of the human brain so far both
of which are involved in creating
memories in one region of the dentate
gyrus a very specific part of the medial
temporal lobe involved in the rapid
formation of new long-term memories and
in the striatum which plays a role in
planning actions reinforcements
motivation and decision-making in the
striatum the cells born in adulthood are
inter neurons exclusively that is they
don't connect to cells outside of their
immediate vicinity and in the medial
temporal lobe the new neurons turn into
granule cells small tightly packed cells
whose reach is also limited locally we
think therefore that adult neurogenesis
enables us to encode new memories giving
us the opportunity to learn throughout
our lives but it doesn't interfere with
connections that we've made from
previous experiences how do we know that
we grow new neurons well some of the
first evidence came from bird brains
songbirds to be precise in the 1980s
scientists found out that Canaries grow
new neurons in the hippocampus the avian
analog of our own memory powerhouse when
they're learning new songs and the more
complex the repertoire the larger their
hippocampus males for example have
larger hippocampal volumes than females
whose songs are less complex mailed you
see have two croon to seduce their mates
and Canaries aren't the only birds in
whom we see learning related
neurogenesis in the hippocampus the
Black capped chickadee can hide up to
ten thousand bits of food in different
places over the course of the autumn and
in order to remember where each snack is
located there hippocampi grow in size in
the fall and winter shrinking back down
in spring and summer when food is easy
to find why
my task through their brains shrink down
again wouldn't it be helpful to keep up
the volume neuro scientists who dismiss
these results as limited to birds argue
that the birds had small brains to begin
with they have to keep themselves light
so that they can fly and so the
adaptation of seasonal memory storage
specific neurogenesis made sense but our
brains are big and we don't have to
worry so much about how much they weigh
so there's no reason to think that such
a power might extend to humans after the
discovery in songbirds however other non
flying animals were shown to possess the
ability to grow new brain cells
neurogenesis in adulthood was
reconfirmed in rodents are relatively
close mammalian cousins genetically
speaking at least you see decades
earlier in the 1960s evidence for the
birth of new brain cells in adult
mammals had already been published and
in prestigious journals - but the
scientific establishment refused to take
the data seriously at the peril of the
careers of those who continued to study
the phenomenon but once the songbird
story came out interest in the topic
began to spread from rodents we've
learned that the speed at which these
new neurons are born can very rich
environments that provide a lot of
stimulation can increase neurogenesis
memory tasks from socializing and even
simple play can - and rats that got a
lot of exercise say by running on a
wheel in one study doubled their
neurogenesis rate compared to sedentary
ones who weren't provided with a running
wheel what's more it's not enough of
course to just grow the new neurons they
also have to survive animals who are
then given the chance to learn a new
skill like balancing on a moving tube
for example were left with a greater
proportion of surviving new cells
compared with a control group who
experienced neurogenesis but then
weren't given the opportunity to put
those cells to action by learning a new
skill and that's one of them
interesting findings from this
literature the new neurons need to be
integrated into addled brains and that
doesn't happen if the animals aren't
challenged once neurogenesis was induced
rats that were given a task that was too
easy
were left with fewer surviving cells
compared with rats given a hard task to
work on and those animals who couldn't
learn the hard task also didn't have as
many remaining new cells as those who
mastered it maybe they weren't trying
hard enough these findings might give us
a clue as to the mechanism by which we
can keep our brains looking young we've
talked about how challenging the brain
in a dolt hood seems to protect it from
cognitive decline
maybe adult neurogenesis is part of the
story here if you don't use those new
cells by learning a new skill for
example they don't get integrated into
your brain but learning a new skill
might be a way to ensure that you don't
waste any newborn neurons despite the
large similarity between our brains and
those of rats there were still prominent
neuroscientists who refused to believe
that adult neurogenesis was a human
thing - then at the turn of the 21st
century a collaboration between
scientists in Sweden and San Diego
finally demonstrated a phenomenon in our
own species the authors have learned
that the same dye used to track
neurogenesis and rodents had been
injected in certain cancer patients over
the previous decades they then got
access to their brain tissue postmortem
and found the same evidence of the birth
of new cells throughout the lifespan in
these people but more questions remained
and that's when the science gets really
exciting when a new discovery leads to
more and better questions now the field
wondered what role neurogenesis plays in
the human mind what circumstances affect
its rate and whether we can treat
devastating brain diseases with neuronal
stem cells
since 2013 a series of studies have been
published that take advantage of the
fact that during the Cold War nuclear
bombs were tested leaving an increase in
the atmosphere in the levels of one
radioactive isotope of carbon carbon-14
and therefore in our cells including our
neurons so scientists can figure out how
old any cell is by measuring the amount
of the isotope in the cells DNA using
this method neuroscientists have learned
that not only is neurogenesis a common
feature of the adult brain but there are
important differences between
neurogenesis and rodents and in humans
in the mammalian brains that we've
studied the growth of new brain cells is
restricted so far we found that in
rodents these neurons end up either in
the olfactory bulb responsible for smell
or the dentate gyrus a sub region of the
hippocampus involved in learning and
memory and as we've discussed the
neurons that are born are fairly small
and make connections only with
neighboring neurons they stay local that
makes sense since integrating new cells
into complicated circuits might be a
recipe for disaster
so both rodents and humans grow new
neurons in the hippocampus and the other
place where new neuron growth begins is
called the subventricular zone in the
lateral ventricle in rodents these
neurons then migrate to the olfactory
bulb likely because the sense of smell
is of critical importance to a rat but
in humans those cells migrate to a part
of the brain called the striatum
responsible for coordinating movement
and critical for long-term learning of
motor and other skills what's called
procedural memory one more really
interesting difference between rat and
human neurogenesis goes exactly against
the logic that some neuroscientists
clung to in justifying their rejection
of the initial findings the idea that
humans can't possibly grow neurons
because we can remember things from a
very remote past
the idea was that if memories are stored
in neural networks those neurons need to
remain intact for us to be able to
retrieve old memories if there was a
turnover of neurons the way there is of
skin cells wouldn't we just forget our
past apparently not
at least not in the dentate gyrus in
rats the proportion of new neurons in
the region doesn't seem to ever exceed
about 10 to 20 percent but in humans by
about age 50 the majority of neurons and
the dentate gyrus have turned over
remarkable how is it possible that we
can still remember old memories then
well there's growing evidence that the
dentate gyrus may play a bigger role in
encoding new memories than in retrieving
old ones in fact rats with dentate gyrus
legions have trouble learning new things
but not remembering old ones leaves in a
different part of the hippocampus one in
which there isn't adult neurogenesis and
you get the opposite pattern the animals
can learn new things but they can't
remember the old ones that would make
sense we'd need the new cells in the
dentate gyrus to form new memories but
then those memories would be ultimately
stored elsewhere and we wouldn't need
that region to retrieve them instead
baby neurons there would now be
available to lay down a new set of
memories leaving us with the ability to
learn new things until the day we die we
now know that decreased adult
neurogenesis plays a role in
neurodegenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's disease and perhaps could be
used in the treatment of Parkinson's
disease where we see a loss of a
specific type of cell it's also been
implicated in depression and
schizophrenia and it's research
continues I'll bet that we'll find many
more conditions in which neurogenesis is
effected at the beginning of the lecture
we talked about the toddler brain and
how it's a wash and braved brain-derived
neurotropic factor or BDNF and that this
hormone affects neuroplasticity Wow
there is a connection between BDNF and
neurogenesis even in adulthood you can
actually influence the amount of BDNF
floating around in your brain and the
growth of new neurons with a fairly
simple and cheap treatment exercise
several studies have shown that regular
exercise can lead to a three-fold
increase in BDNF levels even a single
session can make a difference
exercise is effective at ramping up
neurogenesis and keeping those cells
integrated in the brain and while
exercise can increase adult neurogenesis
stress can impair it in animal models of
depression neurogenesis decreases under
experimental conditions where the
animals are placed under stress in these
same experiments administering and
depressant medications to the stressed
animals has been shown to restore
neurogenesis to healthy rates there are
other examples of people who
successfully increase the volume of
specific parts of their brains by
training or learning a new set of skills
not necessarily by growing new cells but
by increasing the connections between
them a Swedish neuroimaging study for
example tracked the changes in brain
volumes in a group of army recruits
learning Arabic Russian or dari
they compared these changes with those
in medical students who were also
studying intensively though the content
of their learning was very different by
the end of the study the army recruits
showed larger volumes and brain regions
that are involved in processing language
as well as our friend the hippocampus
which is necessary for new long-term
memories for facts and events compared
with the medical students who didn't
show measurable changes in brain size
and these change is correlated with how
well the recruits were doing those who
are mastering the new language and who
were trying harder showed greater
increases in the hippocampus and
language areas compared with recruits
who were struggling or not putting in as
much effort these results are similar to
a now same
study of hippocampus volumes and
students training to be black cab taxi
drivers in London the iconic black cabs
in London are known for their impressive
knowledge of all the streets and
landmarks within a six-mile radius of
Charing Cross because they're so
knowledgeable they charge a higher fee
and that makes their cabs the most
expensive in the city to get a license
to drive a black cab driver tasks to
pass a test called the knowledge it
takes most students two years of daily
work to pass it every day they spend
time in a classroom and then they get on
scooters and race around the city
learning and memorizing the best routes
to different places one seminal early
study compared the volume of the
hippocampus and black cab drivers with
the rest of the population and found a
difference their hippocampal volumes
were indeed different but this study
couldn't address the question of whether
the training itself led to the increase
or if people with larger volumes were
drawn to the job and were more likely to
pass so in a follow-up study the
neuroscientists tracks brain volumes in
a group of student students studying to
pass the knowledge and sure enough
everyone started off with hippocampal
volumes of similar size and when the
study's authors compared the volumes of
the students who passed the test with
those of students who failed they again
found differences the training itself if
it was successful was responsible for
hippocampal growth even juggling every
day for three months has been shown to
increase the volume of certain parts of
the brain including the hippocampus in
20-somethings and in sixty somethings
and while the 60 year olds weren't
juggling as well as the younger
counterparts with the same amount of
training they still showed increases in
brain volume but once the participants
in those experiments stopped juggling
their regions returned to their previous
sizes just like the rats who without an
effortful task to do lost a lot of the
new neurons that they had grown
talk about neuroplasticity however
without mentioning music that's because
musical training has long been used to
demonstrate plasticity in human brains
there are studies that show that
pianists have more of their cortex
devoted to processing sensory motor
information from the hand than the rest
of us and that musicians in general show
measurable brain differences in many
regions but is this nature or nurture at
least one compelling study has shown
that its musical training and not just
genes that's responsible for many of
these differences taking a group of six
year old public school children in
Boston who had no formal music training
scientists randomly assign them to two
groups one group received individual
piano lessons every week and the other
got to sing and play drums and vowels in
a music class at school the groups were
then matched for socioeconomic status
fifteen months later the scientists
scanned their brains again and found
that the group with individual music
lessons showed larger brain volumes in
three areas regions controlling motor
behavior hearing and the corpus callosum
the fiber track that joins the left and
right hemispheres of the brain so it
does seem that musical training can
drive brain volume increases in parts of
the brain that are engaged by the
activity as we get older we tend to
spend less time learning new things or
engaging our brains and effortful ways
and given that this effort is what seems
to benefit our cognitive function and
our brain structure in measurable ways
our lifestyle choices play a significant
role in whether or not we experience
cognitive decline with aging and that
experience in turn can affect our very
attitudes towards longevity for example
if you could choose how long would you
want to live I've been asked that
question twice now in a room full of
people and both times I was surprised at
what the majority of people said they
would choose unlike me it seems that
most people don't want to live longer
than 100
20 years the science writer David Ewing
Duncan conducted an online survey on
this question and found that out of more
than 30,000 responses more than half of
respondents agreed that somewhere around
80 is a good enough lifespan I'm in the
top or bottom depending on your point of
view of the 5% of people who really want
to live forever but perhaps I shouldn't
be so surprised given the hardships but
currently a company aging if continuing
to live just means continuing to suffer
and decline than sure at some point
enough is enough and the stigma that's
associated with old age underscores the
popular belief that things only get
worse
is that true at least in Britain and
Germany surveys of life satisfaction
have shown that it actually steadily
increases between age 40 and 70 if
you're Australian then you're likely to
find peak life satisfaction around age
80
so maybe many of those Duncan survey
respondents were on the right track but
if we managed to stave off physical and
mental decline and save enough money to
economically sustain an extended
retirement I suspect that most people
would push out their desired lifespan
perhaps even past 150 so how much do we
know about the basic biology of Aging
unfortunately at least in the u.s. the
amount of funding for the scientific
study of aging biology pales in
comparison with the amount devoted to
studying diseases of Aging that's a bit
backward in my opinion once we figured
out that smoking increases the risk of
lung cancer we instructed people to smut
stop smoking now we can't just tell
people top aging but shouldn't we be
racing to understand how aging affects
our bodies so that we can slow or
reverse the process rather than focusing
on
asked the vast majority of our resources
on the consequences when it comes to
cognition there are already hints that
interventions designed to keep the body
healthy like exercise have powerful
effects in terms of staving off
age-related mental decline but what
about those people who seem to be able
to stay mentally sharp well into old age
is there something we can learn from
these super Agers there are several labs
now studying not only healthy aging but
super healthy aging people who thrive an
old age and who score as well as people
who are 20 to 30 years younger in one
study for example super Agers are
defined as individuals over the age of
80 who score as well or better than
people who are 50 to 60 years old on a
set of cognitive tests in one study
involving around 30 of these people
scientists found that their anterior
cingulate cortex a region of the brain
responsible for cognitive control
resolving conflict keeping up motivation
and perseverance among other executive
functions was not only larger than that
of their 80 year old peers but also
bigger than the average size in
middle-aged people we still have a long
way to go before we can make any solid
conclusions about what factors combine
to support such successful aging
certainly genes are a factor for most of
us lifestyle choices have a greater
influence on our risk of death before
age 80 and genetics seem to account for
more of the individual variability in
overall health our overall health once
we reach our ninth decade of life in one
study super Agers are pretty varied
attorneys neuroscientists even one
individual who reportedly smokes a pack
of cigarettes a day and caps off each
evening with a martini but what they may
have in common reminds me a little of
our famous sister Mary from an earlier
lecture at least anecdotally they have
remained active members of their
community socializing
regularly and sure enough there's one
more brain finding in this group that's
been reported they have three to five
times more von Economo neurons in their
anterior cingulate cortex than their
peers these large cells are thought to
play a role in facilitating social
interaction and they are the topic of
our next lecture